couch talk into the mic
put her head you want headphones jules
wait headphones
talking the mic hi closer to the mic
yeah so jules do you remember that i
think so
what do you mean you think so i was like
eight or nine oh you were eight or nine
huh look at your little [ __ ] monkey
feet
[Laughter]
have you always had big feet like that
yeah
are you self-conscious about it no you
like your feet
yeah you know what's great about your
feet you can wear my shoes
remember like the shoes that you wear
yeah yeah so let's talk about other
things
just get stuck put your my mouth there
okay okay
so hang on one second yeah is this who i
think it is
from haikyuu ask her about this anime on
her phone baby she's in love with an
anime character
who's this um kobuto
kabuto i love that guy who is that
he's a volleyball player he's a real
volleyball player for what
team um another school i forgot the name
but is that a real human no it's not
it's anime so it's not a real
volleyball player it's a it's nothing
it's absolutely nothing but i still love
them
all right but you know what dude i love
this lighter i love this letter and i
love this thing it doesn't mean that
much does it
but he also talks all right oh
[ __ ] this is what i wanted to get out of
here okay good so
there you go this character in it right
this make-believe character that was
um drawn yeah right
from haikyuu right it's you you have a
measure screensaver
yeah and uh why do you like him he's
very tall
and he's confident and he's very
friendly to a lot of people
oh yes and would you make love to him
[Laughter]
so you would make love to a cartoon
character
wow a lot of people fantasize about that
they do yeah oh they have you ever tried
to masturbate to uh
gente anime porn no i can't do it
is it called
[Laughter]
i saw one where there was just listen
stay here
i saw this one where this octopus
was [ __ ] like six women in the water
well impressive and i almost i was able
to come
almost almost yeah yeah but i couldn't
come when you say
come don't look her in yeah
no i literally was like i was like
almost there but i was like what am i
doing
yeah i think i was like 30th i was i'm
38.
right yeah so have you masturbated
nothing
no i don't know she's 19 years old she's
no she's like no
get out get out okay give her a round of
applause
i'm sorry i'm sorry i [ __ ] up i [ __ ]
up
she's not my daughter though i mean yeah
i know but she's not my daughter with my
flesh and blood i didn't know
you have to protect her at all because
she's uh she is our daughter yeah my bad
sorry george why are you laughing george
loves this kind of content
why why do you like it george it's funny
okay
i apologize she is our daughter yeah
that's so creepy
she's creepy you're old you don't ask an
18 year old high schooler
what she masturbates to you're a creep
if you do that sounds weird when you put
it like that
when you put it in english it's fine